[Music]
what's up good to be here I play a lot
of video games and I actually learned
something about myself playing video
games last week because I went bald when
I was 23 and I always used to tell
myself that that didn't bother me
anymore that I was over it that's what I
would tell myself then I was making my
guy at the beginning of a video game and
I realized that every time I've ever
done that I've given him hair and I
could have made me I'm usually the
default setting I don't have to hit
anything hair none eyes blue skin white
start every video game should be called
John Roy 2k12
because I'm the first thing you see just
me standing there waiting to be selected
I think my cell phone is making me
dumber I used to know any phone number
anyone ever told me ever now they're on
the phone there's jack up here if I lost
my phone now I couldn't even call my dad
I don't know my best friend's phone
number people are like what's Kyle's
number I'm like Kyle's number is Kyle
you hit Kyle that's actor Kevin that's
all I got if I lost my phone I'd have to
get all new friends
I'd be like screw it I'll meet people
I'm not gonna track these people down I
like living in LA though I really do
it's cool it's a diverse city so it's
weird when you still hear racist
nonsense and you still do but it's like
a surprise like two white guys were
behind me in the mall and one of them
goes there's so many Mexicans in this
city it might as well just be a Mexican
city and I was like yeah cuz it was
until 1847 when we conquered it if you
don't want a city full of Mexicans don't
conquer one we took the whole
southwestern Mexico we haven't left
their name in one of the states
we called it New Mexico you know what
the new part was us it's not like they
left when they saw us coming they just
let us switch the flags pretty much
they're like we still work here right
some people don't get that jump there
for real they come up to me after the
show and they're like I like when you
made fun of Mexicans I'm like I did one
of us is a more I think the most
ridiculous racist thing you'll hear
though sometimes white people don't say
this they'll be like well I don't go to
the movies with black people they're
loud they can't control themselves when
I hear that I'm like okay now you know
how they feel when they're in a bar full
of white people and Sweet Caroline comes
on or moni moni or any of the other
songs that white people scream extra
lyrics that we're never on the song to
begin with go on the night go on YouTube
type in Neil Diamond interview watch
them all at no point will Neil look in
the camera and go even though I hired a
professional horn section for Sweet
Caroline the song would sound better if
every drunk white woman from your work
went bad
[Applause]
now I'm not perfect I have some racial
nonsense in my head that I got to get
rid of - it's embarrassing but it's
still there like I freaked out a little
bit when I see black people doing things
I don't expect them to do culturally I
will explain you see a white guys in Jay
Z shirts you think nothing of it but you
meet that one Black Pearl Jam fan and
your brain just melts and every white
rock concerts got at least one black guy
there right and he knows the words he's
singing along and you're like really
your favorite band is Kings of Leon yes
I will play guitar hero with you tonight
but first I have to call my friends and
tell them you exist and sometimes I'll
do that joke and they'll be a lot of
black people in the crowd and one of
them will come up to me and be like
first you look around though and see if
his friends are looking and they'll be
like dude I love Kings of Leon and he's
going but some people here might souks
know like you know what you're making
things too simplistic race is a
complicated issue it's not like you're
saying there's different kinds of races
there's different kinds I don't know if
that's really true I think there's maybe
two there's racists with mustaches and
there's racist without mustaches those
are the two those are two kinds they're
just as racist they just express it
differently like mustache racists are
bold they're like get out of my time
we're as racist without mustaches are
more like I don't know if we should hire
Kevin
[Applause]
is very funny
[Applause]